food continues as merciless assault the
united states and our allies and
partners continue to work in a locked
step
to ramp up the economic pressures on
putin and to further isolate russia in a
global stage
later today together with other nato
allies and the g7 canada
france germany italy japan
united kingdom as well as the european
union we're going to jointly announce
several new steps to squeeze putin and
hold more even more accountable for his
aggression against ukraine
i want to speak to a few of those points
today first
each of our nation is going to take
steps and deny most favored nation
status to
russia
our most favored nation status
designation
means two countries
have agreed to trade with each other
under the best possible terms
low tariffs
few barriers trade
and the highest possible imports allowed
in the united states we call this
permanent normal trade relations pntr
it's the same thing
revoking pntr for russia is going to
make it harder for russia to do business
with the united states
and doing it in unison with other
nations to make up half of the global
economy will be another crushing globe
to the aggression of congress already
suffering very badly from our sanctions
i want to thank speaker pelosi leader
mccarthy leader schumer and mcconnell
and senators wyden and crapo
representative neil and brady for their
bipartisan leadership on this in the
congress
i would like to offer a special thanks
to speaker pelosi who has been a strong
advocate for for revoking pntr and who
agreed to hold off on that in the house
until i could line up all of our key
allies to keep us in complete unison
unity among our allies is critically
important as you all know from my
perspective
many issues divide us
but standing for democracy in ukraine
pushing russia's aggression should not
be one of those issues
the free world is coming together to
confront putin
our two parties here at home are leading
the way
with that bipartisan cooperation i'm
looking forward to signing the law the
bill revoking pntr
which is again most people think of it
as most favored nation status
we're also taking a further step
abandoning imports of goods from several
signature sectors of the russian economy
including seafood vodka and diamonds and
we're going to continue to squeeze
pruning
the g7 will seek to deny russia the
ability to borrow from leading
multinational institutions such as the
international monetary fund and the
world bank
putin is an aggressor he is the
aggressor and putin must pay the price
he cannot pursue a war that threatens
the very foundations which he's doing
the very foundation of international
peace and stability and then ask for
financial help from the international
community
the g7 is also stepping up pressure on
corrupt russian billionaires we're
adding new names to the list of
oligarchs and their families that were
targeted and we're increasing
coordination among the g7 countries to
target and capture their ill-begotten
gains
they support poop
they steal from the russian people
and they seek to hide their money in our
countries
they're part of that kleptocracy that
exists in moscow
they must share the pain
of these sanctions
and
while we're going after
these super super yachts and their
vacation homes for hundreds of millions
of billions of dollars
we're also going to make it harder for
them to buy high-end products
manufactured in our country abandon the
export of lottery luxury goods to russia
they're also the latest steps we're
taking but
they're not the last steps we're going
to take and as i said at the beginning
of all these steps we're going to hit
putin hard because the united states and
our closest allies and partners are
acting in unison
the totality of our sanctions my export
control is crushing the russian economy
ruble has lost more than half its value
they tell me it takes about
200 rules one dollar these days
moscow stock exchange has been closed
for fully for two weeks because they
know the moment it opens it will
probably collapse
credit rating agencies downgraded
russia's government to junk status
its economy to junk status
a list of businesses international
corporations leaving russia is growing
by the day
we're also continuing to close
corporations with allies and partners to
make sure that with close cooperation we
continue to have ukrainian people are
are able to defend their own nation
the united states has sent more than one
billion dollars in security assistance
to crane over the last year
including anti-armor and anti-air
capabilities taking out tanks and planes
and helicopters
with new shipments arriving every day
we in the united states are also
facilitating significant shipments of
security assistance from our allies and
partners to ukraine
and the humanitarian front we're working
closely with the un and humanitarian
organizations to support the people of
ukraine who have been displaced by the
violence of ukraine providing we're
providing tens of thousands of tons of
human supplies for your humanitarian
supplies
food water medicines coming by a truck
and train every single day
yesterday in poland vice president
harris harris announced an additional 53
million dollars in additional
humanitarian support to ukraine
that brings the total humanitarian
assistance to 107 million dollars in
just two weeks
we've joined this effort
by more with more than 30 other
countries for providing hundreds of
millions more
and last night
a great credit to congress passed the
bipartisan spending bill
and included an additional 13.6
billion dollars
in new assistance to the ukrainian
people
i look forward to signing down
immediately
i also want to be clear though
we will make sure ukraine has weapons to
defend against an invading russian force
we will
we will send money food and aid to save
the ukrainian people
and i will welcome ukrainian refugees we
should welcome them here with open arms
if they need access
and we're going to provide more support
from ukraine we're going to continue to
stand together with our allies in europe
send unmistakable message
we'll defend every single inch of nato
territory of the full might of the
united and galvanized nato
we will not fight a war against russia
in ukraine
direct confrontation between nato
and russia is world war iii
something we must strive to prevent
but we already know putin's war against
ukraine will never be a victory
he hoped to dominate ukraine without a
fight he failed he helped to fracture
european resolve he failed helped to
weaken the transatlantic alliance he
failed helped to split apart american
democracies in terms of our positions he
failed
the american people are united the world
is united and we stand with the people
of ukraine we will not let autocrats and
would-be emperors dictate the direction
of the world
democracies are rising to meet this
moment
rallying the world to the side of peace
and the side of security
we're showing our strength
and we will not falter
god bless all of you god bless ukraine
and god bless our troops
president biden president biden your
white house has said that that russia
may use chemical weapons or create a
false flag operation to use them what
evidence have you seen showing that and
would the u.s have a military response
if putin does launch a chemical weapons
attack i'm not going to speak about the
intelligence but but uh russia would pay
a severe price chemical would the u.s
thank you very much
i forgot my sunglasses though which is
the more important part